[Music]
[Applause]
my product is called snacks of Africa I
create coconut chips but not only
coconut chips for African inspired
snacks I'm the chef and creator of a
Spanky's kitchen with a line of vegan
desserts the name our brand is so cacao
we have three chocolate bars not too
traditional chocolate selection and each
only have two ingredients cane sugar and
cacao bean
well Harlem park-to-park is a network of
local entrepreneurs in Central Harlem we
realized that there was a growing
movement in the community of local
artisanal vendors that needed further
support and were of a calibre that were
really ready for larger distribution
than just locally so we partnered with
Columbia University and their Small
Business Development Center as a way to
expand the opportunity and provide more
services to these local businesses the
role of the Columbia University Harlem
Small Business Development Center is
actually to help small businesses in
Upper Manhattan grow expand their
capacity and for this particular event
actually attempt to get contracts with
the University and we're very pleased to
to have created and to be working on
this event because we do find that it's
very important for local vendors to have
access to the right people here at the
University Columbia has a long-standing
history in New York and I think they
work directly with students and they
work within the community and I think
for them it was really important to
ensure that they engage the community as
much as possible and what better way to
do so them to a source locally made food
and products from people you know within
Harlem the name of my company is chapter
JK
and my base is in the ground but I do a
lot of business at home today
I have several cakes and my special
surprise cake is sweet potato cheesecake
with mandarin and I had a conversation
with Lola's the seafood Shack and said
you don't have anything for me and
dining because it's all you care to eat
but we'd love to showcase you at our
chef's table and have you come in show
the students what you can do show some
of our chefs your specialties and then
at the same token advertise your
restaurant to all of the kids we feed on
campus since the university brought the
Columbia Harlem Small Business
Development Center to the University
we've been able to provide technical
assistance and doing outreach in terms
of organizing the marketplace of Harlem
so we're able to use the resources and
the relationships we have here to
benefit local vendors other you know
local entrepreneurs and in this instance
we're really organizing a kind of an
organic food operation that's evolving
out of the community and providing them
with opportunities so that they'll be
able to grow and become thriving
businesses well I think have been given
part of in Columbia
with the students I think they would
love the angles because you know when
they doing term papers and they studying
it's a million one you take one by keys
and Wow
and you keep eating it and you're
getting fresh quality vegetables in a
roll Harlem as a community and as a
market is going through tremendous
change and so with that change it's
really really important that Harlem as a
community with such a tremendous
cultural legacy that that's preserved
and the way that can be done is through
supporting the local small businesses so
the more we support small businesses
local entrepreneurs the more we preserve
that neighborhood charm that will
prevent Harlem from losing what is the
essence of the neighborhood which we
find to be really the strongest asset
that we have